what do you really know about how the
dutton family came to be what guest
stars are actually doing their real life
job on the show everything gator might
actually be doing the cooking off screen
yellowstone fans have taylor sheridan to
thank for bringing the series to life
sheridan is the one who first began
setting the groundwork for what would
become yellowstone way back in 2013. if
his name was ringing a bell it's
probably because he's one of hollywood's
biggest up and coming behind the scenes
talents after a short career as an actor
that saw him taking on a small part on
veronica mars and a recurring role as
deputy chief of police david hale on
sons of anarchy sheridan decided to move
behind the camera in fact it was his
weariness of acting that turned him to
screenwriting in the first place thus
motivating him to create yellowstone
sharon is best known for his first two
efforts as a screenwriter 2015 sicario a
visceral tale of an fbi agent's descent
into the world of mexico's cartel wars
was met with widespread acclaim his
follow-up the modern western heller high
water nabbed him an oscar nomination for
best original screenplay he also wrote
and directed the 2017 film wind river
before successfully pitching his idea
for yellowstone the impetus for
yellowstone came from a desire to tell a
story about gentrification in the
american west in an interview with
deadline sheridan explained it is the
most american of us the west and land
developers sell that fantasy and people
who can afford the fantasy are very very
wealthy people from la to new york
dallas and florida in the process those
land values and inheritance taxes are
killing a way of life
one of the most significant factors that
draws viewers to yellowstone is its star
oscar award winner kevin costner it's
the multi-talented actor's first time
starring on a tv series besides a
limited mini-series hatfields and
mccoy's jared and viewed costner's
involvement as an integral part of
setting the show's tone and style he
told variety in june 2018 kevin's one of
the biggest movie stars of the past 40
years and well deserved he's an
incredible storyteller as a director as
a writer as an actor and so when you
have that kind of tool in your toolbox
you can write him into some really
conflicting situations you know having a
conversation with you is like a is
is like a martian talking to a fungo as
it turns out there's a reason costner
has been slow to make the leap to tv he
told indy wire in 2019 that he's had
difficulty feeling comfortable creating
a character without knowing what their
full arc was he described the process as
a more vulnerable way to go through life
as an actor even going so far as to say
it hasn't been an easy adjustment for me
i don't like it too much despite his
misgivings about working in television
costner has been effusive in his praise
for sheridan in an interview with
collider the actor said of sheridan's
work ethic he's had to pay a lot of dues
and a lot of things he's cleaned out a
lot of horse stalls in hollywood so to
speak
as with any massive tv production things
haven't always gone smoothly behind the
scenes of yellowstone according to
deadline the show hit its first
roadblock before its pilot had even
aired and only months after paramount
network had greenlit the production for
the first season of yellowstone
paramount network partnered with the
weinstein company who agreed to produce
the series however on october 2017 the
new york times and the new yorker
published reports of the weinstein
company co-founder harvey weinstein's
history of sexual harassment and abuse
swift action was then taken to distance
weinstein from yellowstone they released
a statement declaring that weinstein's
name would be removed from the credits
for both yellowstone and another
co-produced show for the network titled
waco the president of paramount network
kevin k also stood firm in their
decision during a press tour as reported
by deadline the exec explained there are
hundreds of people who worked on both
waco and yellowstone and these people
shouldn't be penalized that has nothing
to do with them and we want a safe
workplace nobody wants to be associated
with the things that went on there when
pressed about weinstein's involvement on
yellowstone and waco k added i want to
say definitively that harvey weinstein
has never been a part of the creative
process until a new name of the company
is announced weinstein company will not
be listed in the credits for either show
the primary dramatic focus of
yellowstone is on the white dutton
family however their proximity to the
fictional broken rock indian reservation
an ongoing feud with tribe chairman
thomas rainwater means that native
american characters are featured
prominently on the show as well
controversy erupted over the casting of
actress kelsey asbill in the role of
monica long dutton a native american
woman and the wife of one of the
dutton's sons as bill had previously
claimed to be of chinese and cherokee
descent shoon magazine described her in
a july 2018 profile as part cherokee and
half chinese presumably because that's
what she said during the interview a
november 2018 profile of as bill and w
magazine also described her as being of
chinese english and cherokee descent she
told the publication it's been a
blessing to get to explore native
culture on yellowstone as a person of
mixed race as you get older it matters
more to you who you are and where you
come from so to be able to get in touch
with that side of my heritage has been
amazing however according to native news
source penchaga.net asbelle's assertions
might not be as accurate as she would
have us believe when her claims were
presented to the eastern band of
cherokee indians the tribe tribaspill
claimed her lineage to send it from they
responded with a statement declaring no
documentation was found on our records
to support any claim that she descends
from the eastern band of cherokee
indians outside of the casting
controversy several native american
people involved in the show's production
have spoken highly of their experiences
veteran actor gil birmingham told indian
country today that he was thrilled to be
on the show saying one of the highlights
is to have a prominent native american
character and a contemporary piece
that's empowered and not playing a
victimization portrayal he's also
praised sheridan's handling of native
issues but clarified by adding it would
be nice if we could get some more native
writers included by getting work for as
many people as we can is a good start
our first fight
is against being ignored
aj not afraid chairman of the crow
nation whose reservation stands in for
the fictional broken rock reservation
also praised the portrayal of
contemporary native americans in
yellowstone he told variety that when it
came to the representation of native
american characters yellowstone is a lot
more realistic than other shows
in 2018 animal rights advocacy group
peta claimed that a whistleblower who
worked on the set of yellowstone
informed them that the show used actual
dead bovines in a scene that depicted
mutilated cow carcasses they
characterized this as both wasteful and
having the potential to expose the cast
and crew to disease furthermore the
whistleblower noted that the carcasses
were left out in the sun for a long
period of time during filming and
produced a stench that was difficult for
the crew to later wash away paramount
network denied this claim shortly after
it became public the company's svp of
communications kurt patta said in a
statement paramount network takes animal
safety very seriously and with the
utmost professionalism the production
has taken necessary precautions to
provide for animal safety and their
well-being on set all animals are
monitored on set by professional
handlers we have been in touch with peta
which presented us with inaccurate
claims that we were able to correct
including no cows were killed or
mutilated for the scene in question
thankfully this is the only claim of
animal cruelty that yellowstone has
faced
just because yellowstone centers on
family and political conflict doesn't
mean that filming hasn't gotten intense
speaking with parade magazine actress
kelly riley who plays the smart and
scary beth dutton described a
particularly harrowing day on set she
explained that she had to film a scene
where her character runs toward a pack
of wolves during a very unorthodox date
the scene involved beth yelling at said
pack of wolves as they attempted to feed
which only intensified her worries about
everything going south riley said they
were real wolves they were tame but they
were still real wolves they had like
invisible fishing line on them with two
people lying in the grass so if they had
charged me i kept saying to them you
really think that that's going to stop
them and they were like well we can't do
anything else in another incident riley
described how she almost fell victim to
a bad google maps recommendation during
a break from filming while attempting a
day trip the british actress took a
shortcut and found herself on a
precarious montana mountain road in the
middle of december in an ill-equipped
car she told parade that her first
reaction when returning to level ground
was of shock and gratitude saying i
can't believe i survived
following the finale of yellowstone
season 3 an interviewer for deadline
asked taylor sheridan how members of his
cast took to horseback riding after all
sheridan himself appears skillful on
horseback during his cameo appearances
on the show he revealed that beth dutton
actor kelly riley is the most
experienced writer the viewers might not
know this given that of the main players
her character spends the least amount of
time on a horse jimmy heardstrom actor
jeffrey white meanwhile had to learn how
to ride a horse more or less from
scratch sheridan said we had him out
there two or three days in a row
horseback riding is all about trust
between horse and rider it takes a lot
of trust for someone who has never been
on a horse to get on one and the horse
can feel that fear so it was pretty
dicey for a bit to his credit the second
day i had him out there just riding
never complaining and when he got off he
said i'll fix this i promise don't worry
jimmy it will all be over soon some of
the ranchers featured on yellowstone
meanwhile are professionals in their
real lives a video shared by paramount
network to its youtube channel details
how real-life cowboy jake ream started
working behind the scenes of yellowstone
before he was offered an on-camera roll
his character who was simply named jake
allowed him to finally show off his
wrangling skills on tv
dedicated viewers of yellowstone know
that the dutton family employs a cook
named gator perhaps most famously gator
makes beth a smoothie consisting of
three scoops of ice cream and three
shots of vodka for her specifications as
it turns out gator is portrayed by a man
actually nicknamed gator with the birth
name of gabriel gilbo in addition to
bringing his real-life nickname to the
character gilbo is likewise an
experienced chef who is responsible for
many of the meals served to the
yellowstone cast and crew in a profile
of the man paramount network shared to
its youtube channel jimmy herdstrom
actor jefferson white claimed anybody on
the crew anybody in the cast can't talk
about the show for five minutes without
mentioning gator actor ian bowen
described gobo's presence on sets as
essentially a restaurant open from crew
call to rap where you can have whatever
you want though gilboa was born near
santa barbara california he grew up in
louisiana which influenced his style of
cooking on his personal instagram
account gilbo often shows off some of
the meals he cooks during the filming of
yellowstone like for example a pair of
whole pigs he served to its cast and
crew he also recently headed craft
services for the fx on hulu comedy
reservation dogs he posted a few
different meals he cooked up for them
during the making of that series too
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]